>> I DON'T EVEN KNOW WHAT THE
[ BLEEP ] THIS MEANS.
I'M GOING TO GOOGLE THIS
[ BLEEP ].
(KNOCKING)
LET ME CALL YOU BACK.
CAN I TALK TO YOU FOR A MINUTE
ABOUT SOMETHING?
>> OF COURSE.
MY OFFICE IS SU OFFICE.
>> THANK YOU.
JOYCE FROM TALENT KEEPS
HITTING ON ME.
SHE KEEPS SENDING ME
INAPPROPRIATE EMAILS AND PUTTING
SUGGESTIVE PICTURES ON MY DESK.
I'M MARRIED.
WHAT DO YOU THINK I SHOULD DO?
>> NUT UP AND RUN WITH IT.
OKAY. NUT UP. THANK YOU.
(LAUGHTER).
THANK YOU.
>> TYPE, TYPE, TYPE.
(LAUGHTER)
♪♪
>> HEY.
I NEED TO TALK TO YOU ABOUT
SOMETHING.
>> OF COURSE, I'M NOTHING IF NOT
AN EAR TO BEND
>> OK, GREAT.
BECAUSE I THINK COLLEEN IS
STEALING FROM THE OFFICE.
SHE STOLE 8 REAMS OF PAPER THE
OTHER DAY AND --
>> STOP SNITCHIN, MOTHER[ BLEEP
]!
OKAY.
(LAUGHTER)
(APPLAUSE)
>> KNOCK-KNOCK.
WHAT'S UP, CAM'RON?
GOING ON?
E GOT A LITTLE BIT OF A
PERSONNEL SITUATION HERE THE
HEAD OF H.R.
WE'RE LOOKING TO GET RID OF OUR
WRITER'S ASSISTANT.
I WAS HOPING WOULD YOU HELP ME
OUT WITH THE PAPERWORK
OFFICIALLY.
>> PAPERWORK IS A LITTLE TOO
MUCH.
I'LL TAKE CARE OF HIM.
>> GREAT, I GOT A TON ON MY
PLATE
(APPLAUSE)
>> HEY, CAM'RON, WHEN YOU SAY
"TAKE CARE OF IT," CAN YOU
CLARIFY EXACTLY WHAT YOU MEAN BY
"TAKE CARE OF IT."
>> I KNOW A GUY WHO'LL DO IT FOR
US
DO WHAT EXACTLY?
TAKE CARE OF WHAT [ BLEEP ]
NEEDS TO BE DONE.
I NEED AN INTERN WHO WILL GET 20
LARGE OUT OF PETTY CASH FOR ME
AND TAKE IT TO A MAILBOX
IN FLATBUSH.
>> I THINK MAYBE JUST -- I'LL
TALK TO HIM.
I KNOW YOU GOT A LOT ON YOUR
PLATE.
>> YOU'RE THE BOSS.
THANKS, MAN.
COOL.
>> HELLO?
00:02:00,687 --> 00:00:00,000
TELL THAT INTERN TO TAKE THAT
20 LARGE TO MY CRIB.